We'll need to pass in some values in order to
meaningfully discuss this question.
So, let's make some here.
Furthermore, I'm going to make the variable names reflect the color of
the value that they store.
At this point, now that we have some values, we can finally call the function,
passing in a couple of the objects that we've made, so
we can see how they're treated.
Input parameters to a function only have bindings when that
function is actually running.
So only now that we have an example of invocation can we really
meaningfully evaluate what we expect parameter two to be bound to.
So what do you expect to be logged in this example?